allora da un menù così mi aspetta ma chi
è romain matteo roma se siete stati
bravi a creare questo gioco che vi
ringrazio però cambiate nome per
cortesia sottilissimi ricordo un sacco
me durante l'esame di maturità per skate
start let's go baby non so bene cosa si
tratta beh è un gioco ideato da einstein
sta arrivando una palla di cannone si
schianterà micah micah qui
beh sono ne sono sono morti bene se
proprio vi sia piaciuto male non fa
niente let's go ragazzi siamo su non so
bene che gioco sia si chiamano migranti
ma chi se ne frega chissene giochiamo si
chiama palla lo invento io nome palla
con la lingua di fuori
chi guarda i video dei favi gen si
riduce così quindi non usufruita né
troppo bene schivato palle in una
maniera incredibile nakis of this andava
così bene poi ai ragazzi sono stat alla
che deve arrivare entro un minuto è sono
morto ma cosa devo fare io esattamente
dove c'è un punto d'arrivo il suo gioco
è tutto così la musica non so se la
sentì tema la musica mi turba al
tantissimo anche andiamo no no no non
riesco a saltare sopra ok perfetto ma le
palle di cannone sono direzionate si
immagino di sì occhio che dobbiamo
muoverci che qua è tutto la roccia e
tutta franabile casomai sarà friabile
non franabile comunque frara non è che
fiat si sta andando avanti
no ho battuto la testa sono una testa
perfetto e schivate incredibile
no non è vero nella vita
lo sapevo che cascava allora è un gioco
abbastanza per deficienti quindi non
posso non vincere credo allora calmi
tutti qua e la situazione è grave
bisogna avere un quoziente intellettivo
di almeno 100 per poter vincenzo gioco
l'ho letto prima qui non so quanto sia
favorita in questa o perso a prescindere
siamo tornati davvero prima dove secondo
prima però dall'altra parte quindi non
sapendo dove andrà a finire ma c'è un
traguardo in sto gioco che cosa devo
fare io della mia vita spiega mi sta
crollando aiuto amici dove andare cosa
devo fare
e vabbè vabbè è crollato di tutto e come
va bene fa niente
non sto capendo dove devo andare è
crollato tutto mi date una mano per
cortesia non so dove devo andare
non mi ha colpito quindi tutto ok tutto
ok tutto ok tutto che tutto che hai
tutto bene ci son delle robe laggiù però
non penso di riuscire ad arrivare fin
laggiù non capisco cosa devo fare il suo
gioco sporco demonio morto ieri che male
sono vivo ca di tutti perfetto perfetto
via via via via via via vai vai vai vai
vai mai
mancano 20 secondi provare esistere si
20 secondi capire che cosa paga dire
finire solo il tempo magari un gioco a
tempo devi resistere 20 secondi io non
lo sapevo
non fatemi crollare questo non fatemi
crollare sta roba per cortesia finito il
tempo
no a munition lepri lodi maya come
reloading o no non lo so ha tenuto
perché sono scemo quanto sono scemo da
una mille li mortacci mia dovevo
resistere
ok li melo tipo 2 minuti prima che dice
ma dai che lo passa reines tributi e
faccio i punti di vista
se passano i buchi ma non faccio punti
anzi muoio quindi pessima idea best time
meno 105 resisto due minuti e vediamo
dove va a finire
aiuto aiuto dove vado crolla tutto qua
che male sono schiacciato sono
schiacciarmi ha schiacciato una e
dovette spostarmi sta roba mia
schiacciato mi sta schiacciando non
capire sono vivo ma schiacciato vabbè
non fa niente rimaniamo così ok no
munition l'est
ma non è vero il running out of space
vai vai che male che male ok mi sa che è
bellissimo codis farà fortissima e
bellissimo se non fosse un problema il
fatto che che non riesca a resistere più
di tanto il suo gioco però è veramente
bello ma perché ma perché
ma perché ma perché così difficile
soggiorno perché tra tutti i giochi dopo
uno così casi nato sono su una colonna
che si tiene su con uno stuzzicadenti
perché demonio mi vuole male perché è
difficilissimo che lo giuro resiste la
strada è difficilissimo noi farci
chilometri mi sono rotto le palle di
farci km vedere quanto resisto e
difficili non riesco a resistere quei
due minuti è impossibile comunicare
qualcosa in testa arriva una bacca dal
dal cielo la madre degli haters non lo
so impossibile ve lo giuro è impossibile
resistere impossibile mi arriva un
mission a certa mi fa fuori per forza
allo ragazzi credo di aver trovato la
tattica dopo sei ore di gioco breve se
io vado piano lui mi fa fuori tutte le
piattaforme però in realtà mela me la
vivo scialla la faccenda
basta solo evitare di essere schiacciato
dalle cose che mi bloccano la vivo molto
serenamente questa cosa
è così che dovete vivervi compiti in
classe e tutto un disastro va tutto lo
scatafascio passate tranquilli che la
vita è bella e difficilissima perché poi
nizza essere tutto distrutto e non sai
dove salta recapito 10 secondi
vai limite se la palla non dà a cadere
sul mio la mia piattaforma 4 3 2 1 fa mi
vedevi così capace fa rivedere for cazzo
sola via via via via
il record in record cavalca quanto
difficile
ora promemoria è difficilissimo e un
gioco bellissimo è veramente difficile
cioè per resistere più di tot è
impossibile da parata pare bava
mi piace la canzone in sè per sè non è
un gioco brutto però ma la mia lingua
esattamente il soggetto a cosa serve
ma la domanda è lecita perché non so c'è
una lingua gigantesca la canzone
veramente stupenda demonia martos e
riesco a salire sulle cose weil etica o
ok allora momento non ci fosse facciamo
lo facciamo sempre concentrato
concentrato concentra ados
salta ci arrivi ok secco mi metto qui
sopra che cosa però non ci vengo mai
sono pronto a ricevere le verifiche di
chimica eccole qui questa è la mia vita
che va allo scatafascio al liceo
filosofico il suo gioco è carino io
vorrei andare lì dove sta crollando
tutto non so se una bell'idea perché ci
provo sono masochista non so se lo
sapete per te che ci provo molto bene no
ora gav e lo giuro su quello che volete
che vorrei staccarlo perché vabbè però
gli aveva tirato abbastanza
intrattenimento fuori da questo gioco
cioè perché più di così non ce n'è però
è talmente una droga che mi vendo a
continuare non so perché il parco schifo
il demonio lo so perché sa perché voglio
farmi così male ci vuole momento zen
commento zen tattica del secolo fermi
immobili
diciamo che ci bombardino ci leviamo
solo quando crolliamo
solo quando crolliamo dell'astro per ora
gli hobbit prova a lanciarmi qualche
palla 6 coraggio o magari un po più ecco
perfetto questa attenzione mi casca di
sopra questa mi casca di sopra questo mi
carica di so proprio se mi casca di
sopra ciao bene e stato divertente un
minuto cammino che sono andato vabbè
l'abbiamo fatto fuori tutta la prima
piattaforma praticamente cucire un po
più strano del solito di può passar di
quarta volta è records e 98 stavolta non
lo batto più regalo non sento proprio
quella su cui volevo salire proprio
guardate che quell'incidente
dio mio
mamma mia che salvataggio incredibile
via via via via è stata veramente brutta
la faccenda mi sta crollando tutto e
tutti i posti dovevano salire io mi sta
crollando quindi sa che non salirò
proprio qui ma proviamoci molto bene va
bene alla spettasse a scappare in giro
più tranquillo magari però saltare su
un'altra piattaforma via via gli dico a
via di qua via proviamo
violo jolo dai dai dai che ce la faccio
da chi ce la faccio no no non era morto
almeno morto tua madre era morta non io
guarda bene porco demonio non ero morto
dai non ero morto lo salito sulla
colonna affrettato ma perché non ero
morto rega la mia vita è paragonabile a
questo gioco comunque molto molto simile
tutte le volte in cui nella vostra vita
rimarrete delusi
avrete una giornata no vi crollerà il
mondo addosso ecco guardate questo video
secondari li prendete un attimo pensate
che la vostra vita non deve essere
brutta così come crollano questi palazzi
deve essere bella quanto questa palla va
beh non quando questa pochi bella di
quella palla 14 st ricordando tutto
esattamente dove devo andare io però non
è 98 aiuto 43
fammi vedere i colossi capace satana
dimostramelo allora ma per favore
quando mi spara che cosa impossibile
però vi sia piaciuto il video ragazzi
come al solito c'è il video mi è
piaciuto il suo documento o mi piace
anche ai vari social che come non
dividono descrizione se non sono persone
schiette e non ci vediamo allora vedo
bene grazie
[Musica]